[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in gary klein who's kind
enough to join us this morning covers
the rams for the la times how would you
sum up last night's performance gary
well i think for the rams i think jimmy
garoppolo used a term along the lines of
it was kind of a soul-sucking drive that
uh that first 18-play march that the the
49ers just kind of ran it down their
throat and as you mentioned i think kyle
j uh kyle shanahan's just been masterful
at
not putting garoppolo in situations
where he's going to make mistakes and
the last few times they've played the
rams
he's played error-free and we've seen
what happened
were you surprised last night
you know dan i will say i chose the
49ers to win that game just because of
all the turmoil that was going on with
the rams and some of that was good in
terms of you know the von miller trade
odell beckham jr is acquired but then
when they lost robert woods uh just a
few days before the games uh kind of an
unheralded player that is really key to
that offense
and again with you know with the history
with the 49ers it just seemed like the
rams were ripe to be beat for the second
time in a row explain to the audience
the value of robert woods
well this is a a player damn that
actually i've covered when he was a
freshman at usc so i've seen him grow up
um and even from those early days he's a
guy that is not going to complain a very
talented receiver but really does
everything especially in the blocking
game he's a guy that that they match up
against defensive linemen linebackers
and just kind of very unselfish and
gives cooper cup and other receivers an
opportunity to to run all kinds of
routes a great receiver in his own right
but really just from a team leader
standpoint from all those things that
you don't see necessarily uh in the stat
box he's been instrumental to their
success since he signed as a free agent
uh in 2017. can odell beckham jr
fill that role
you know i don't think that they're
going to ask
odell beckham jr to to actually fill
that role because he's not a blocker at
least he hasn't been you know throughout
his career not not at the level of
robert woods so sean mcvay is going to
have to figure out how to get him
involved and of course early in the
season you know they they signed deshaun
jackson to give them that deep threat
and then they really couldn't figure out
a way to get him any touches so mcveigh
didn't waste any time last night obj got
the first play of the game they went to
him so it's obvious they want to get him
involved but it's going to take him more
than one day
to fit into that offense
i don't know what to expect out of
matthew stafford
because
you know
wait first couple of months pretty good
but you know when it comes to big games
we want to see what he does in a big
game and it feels like this success or
failure of this team might be more
predicated on matthew stafford than
aaron donald von miller jalen ramsey or
odell beckham jr what do you make of
matthew stafford so far
well
when they traded for matthew stafford
that was their first sign right that the
rams are all in okay they've got to get
to the super bowl this year with stan
kroenke and sofi stadium they have to be
playing in that game and i think the
first part of the season stafford was an
mvp candidate he looked he looked great
um but these last few games he has made
some decisions and some plays that
really for rams fans i mean i'm in the
press box but you can almost hear fans
going oh my god that's what jared goff
did he's had some series like that
and uh you know he's a veteran
quarterback my sense is that
with and gary froze up there this by
week he'll come back but uh this the
ultimate test is gonna be when they get
to the playoffs
better team the rams are chargers
uh i would say the rams at this point
but uh justin herbert is a terrific
quarterback
and uh getting back to that pressure dan
you know i can't even imagine a scenario
if the chargers really start playing
well and somehow get to the super bowl
and dean spanos is in that owner's suite
for the super bowl instead of stan
kroenke that would be an absolute
disaster for the rams handicapped the
rams the second half of the season bye
week and then you got the packers coming
up uh how tough is this schedule going
to be
well i think for even for a team that
was playing as well as the rams this was
going to be a tough stretch you've got
road trips to green bay to minnesota to
baltimore all on holiday weekends by the
way
jacksonville comes into town but you got
to go on the road to play the cardinals
as well uh and then also the seahawks
come come to your place and the 49ers
who've been invincible against the rams
finished the season at sofi stadium so
it is not an easy schedule by any means
and if the rams can't get it together uh
they're gonna have some issues yeah
because you could end up as the five
seed and i mentioned you could be going
to dallas and then going to green bay or
tampa bay and
i don't know is this team equipped to be
able to
string together a couple of uh on the
road playoff wins
well under mcvay they've been pretty
successful on the road but you know the
nfc is so stacked and if you look at the
rams they've only beaten one team tampa
bay buccaneers early in the season that
has a winning record oh they lost to the
tennessee titans they lost to the
cardinals um you know they're and
they're even losing now to the stanford
you know the 49ers who are probably
better than that than that three and
five record they had but they've got a
lot to prove they they looked like a
super bowl team early in the season but
17 games the longest season in nfl
history um they've got they've got a
long road ahead what about the uh the
cardinals are they still the team to
beat
well they still are dan but you know
going into the season i don't i don't
think i'm alone in thinking i keep
waiting for the cardinals to be the
cardinals right to blow it to not be
able to maintain this uh but when they
were winning you know the week before
with colt mccoy without even kyler
murray uh they do seem like they have
some staying power and that defense is
pretty good even without jj watt uh so i
don't think you can at this point 10
games in expect the cardinals to fold
like they might have in the past and the
rams lost a great opportunity last night
to gain some ground
gary thank you we appreciate your time
and uh uh hopefully we uh get an
opportunity to cross paths again thank
you
thanks dan that's a gary klein he covers
the rams for the la times